this is Oklahoma one of the many places
in America where catfish is high on the
menu it has a similar taste of cod or
halibut and the rivers lakes and swamps
of the American South are calling with
this delicious fish this little beauty
here is cotton chips to the locals is
the most amazing Philly's of catfish
they've been coated in cornmeal lightly
fried and they taste absolutely [ __ ]
delicious
you can only buy farm catfish and
Oklahoma if you want to experience the
taste of it wild you need to catch them
yourself
Oh mr. ramse how I sir I'm gonna be
taught to noodle for mine by local
champion Lee McFarlin I'm excited to be
here
noodling tell me what is but it's the
act of getting in the water to catch a
giant catfish with your bare hands
I must have chances of being bitten be
like a pit bull ready when he grabs hold
of you he'll bite you and make you say
words you have it certain long time
you can't noodle on your own so we're
taking the family with us it'll be like
fishing with the Waltons but hopefully
their expertise will ensure we grab a
decent catch
this is Lee's prized patch Carl
Blackwell Lake a stretch of water six
miles long and four miles wide the clay
turns the water a murky orange color
which makes what I'm about to do ten
times harder now usually I'd cast the
line out and wait all day for a bite
hoping to land a big [ __ ] catfish but
here on this Lake they noodle so
basically all you need is a big pair of
hands and a big pair of bollocks this
Lake his team lure catfish and Lee knows
it like the back of his hand
we're heading to his best noodling spots
with cousin mark and his son-in-law Josh
how do we see them Yahtzee so we like
feeling in the dark y-yeah and that's
first time bang catfish hiding cracks
and holes below the surface
the Native Americans thought grabbing
them by hand was the best way to find
food and people have been noodling here
ever since
first we need to find the holes on the
bed of the lake using our feet quite big
hold on isn't it a little scary that's
quite eerie I can't see [ __ ] all yelling
honesty Joey and I'm using my feet in my
hands I don't like fishing blind your
heart surrounded by bushland the lake is
full of black snakes and snapping
turtles and wearing gloves to prevent my
fingers being bitten off wasps to go
under and dig deep nothing else down
there nothing else is in there we run
check by going underwater I could reach
us far into the holes as possible long
way back your image will have they get
home get yes big big white shirt we also
check holes in the river banks which are
easy to get to but just as dangerous
this is feel so sticky stick your hand
in the [ __ ] hole angelfish the biteys
they can grab you by the gills and pull
the [ __ ] out oh let's go and do you
bark you drag mark Leah's found our
first catfish and is attaching a rope
through its mouth underwater to help
stop he escaping oh man let's see what
you got
[ __ ] I stick to like that he then
leaves me to do the hard bit pulling the
fish out of his hole [ __ ] [ __ ]
bloody hell but success is brief one
minute is in my hands and the next it
slips off the rope and gets the way [ __ ]
sorry on that part of the game another
hour another location on the lake and in
less than 20 minutes
Lia's found another one fill that hole
over there this time it wasn't going
anywhere
you had to go under yeah
is that you got a deal
oh [ __ ] guys it bit me Hey
the bigger the catfish the tasty the
flesh and these boys will tell you this
is by far the best way to bag a decent
catch oh [ __ ] made a big one for that
beauty lovely and now catch was proof I
was fishing with some of the best
Noodlers in the business Jesus tries to
some weight now ah good job
well cut their tails and let them bleed
ready yeah cuz if you don't you'll have
a lot of blood and that meat yeah that's
like we do to pig mmm that's amazing I
never knew you had to drain them and
your father showed you this way my
father taught me all this right I've
learned how to noodle properly now got a
skin one and then fill it one
to skin one yeah what you've got if you
look right here you just barely one
pierce the skin here's the next thing
just like catching them Lee makes
skinning the catfish look easy now it's
my turn the bowel under the bone tap in
one day times [ __ ] pair of pliers and
a penknife
they went down like Tecla flights off
there you go unbelievable now he's
raised to play look how white that
fleshes but if we wouldn't have cut the
tail yeah they'd been all solid red down
through there you wanted as wide as that
got it's so tough
so why they so cheap cuz they're they're
raising them in ponds these are wild the
taste is a lot different because these
are bigger see I just think everyone's
got the wrong impression for catfish you
know that they do these are the best eat
from that big mother that is delicious
refreshing noodle catfish skinned
fileted and now we're gonna cook them
Cajun style I'm making a delicious fiery
marinade using paprika cayenne pepper
and dried thyme that makes the fish a
lot more fragrant tablespoon of garlic
powder seasoned with salt pepper and
olive oil the juice of two lemons
helps to season the fish and more
importantly it works the marinade a lot
quicker give that a little mix from
there roll the catfish around the
marinade already the catfish is starting
to absorb that marinade and then from
there heat the pan nice and hot olive
oil in get some color on the catfish to
seal it and give it some flavor
that's we won there that really nice
blackened flavor and that's why it's
Cajun style the glaze of white wine to
take the kick out of the spices and to
keep the fish moist and then from there
we make our vinaigrette two parts olive
oil fresh lemon juice salt pepper and a
tablespoon of white wine vinegar a
little pinch of dried thyme nice mix
that up
sell it on touch of vinegar over there
before the catfish comes out a nice drop
fresh lemon beautiful our lovely out
onto the plate once the catfish is
cooled down what we'll do now is just
get the catfish and just open up and
look got that really nice black and
flavor on the outside layer inside the
lettuce and that has to be the most
amazing way of eating catfish right you
redneck noodle as you ready mmm mmm that
delicious and best I'm fast and healthy
mmm the flavor like a catfish is
extraordinary you normally fry yours
this josh is a an alternative a lot
healthier
so next time you're noodling you can fit
down all those little cracks yeah please
redeem himself go am i officially a
redneck now you're a redneck thank you
that's one choke I'll never forget I can
assure you
spinach chicory fricassee iceberg fennel
spinach broccoli
we've got michelin-starred monkeys